Caption: all right so our first talk for today is
Caption: Ricky Barnes who will be speaking about
Caption: Escaping The Vortex or how I learned to
Caption: stop procrastinating and get things done
Caption: mostly
Caption: so a little bit about Ricky Ricky Barnes
Caption: is a full stack developer contributing
Caption: to challenging The Impossible at the
Caption: minduru foundation her colleagues know
Caption: her as a hard worker with an eye for
Caption: detail
Caption: from her first homework extension in
Caption: year three through two undergraduate
Caption: degrees and over 15 years of Industry
Caption: experience Ricky has honed a
Caption: procrastination abilities to a truly
Caption: expert level
Caption: despite several gratifying achievements
Caption: such as never handling in a single
Caption: assignment on time throughout her second
Caption: degree
Caption: has embarked on a course correction of
Caption: avoiding distractions prioritizing daily
Caption: objectives and claiming back her time
Caption: for real goals and priorities
Caption: all right thank you Ricky
Caption: hi everyone as you heard I am a lifelong
Caption: procrastinator and about a year ago I
Caption: decided to get serious about trying to
Caption: be more effective because I'm not just
Caption: an accomplished procrastinator I'm also
Caption: very easily distracted and honestly
Caption: being an easily distracted
Caption: procrastinator
Caption: is very frustrating I end up cross with
Caption: myself a lot and being a little bit like
Caption: why are you like this I say this to
Caption: myself all the time
Caption: I called my talk Escaping The Vortex
Caption: because Vortex is a shorthand that one
Caption: of my friends and I have always used to
Caption: explain this Behavior where you get
Caption: sucked into something and you can't seem
Caption: to stop yourself from doing it and
Caption: that's even if you've got something else
Caption: that you should be doing or even if
Caption: there's something else that you would
Caption: rather be doing
Caption: so I'm assuming since you're all here
Caption: you know how it feels to get sucked into
Caption: the Vortex right
Caption: so why do we get sucked into the Vortex
Caption: there's a couple of reasons
Caption: I think it's because the way our brains
Caption: are wired makes us susceptible to growth
Caption: both procrastination and distraction and
Caption: also because the things that are meant
Caption: to engage us specifically leverage that
Caption: in order to hook us in
Caption: I'm gonna look at the reasons why we
Caption: procrastinate and how understanding that
Caption: can help us overcome it I'm going to
Caption: give a couple of examples of when I've
Caption: procrastinated dissect the reasons
Caption: behind it and then show the strategies
Caption: that I use to get back on track
Caption: with distraction we're going to discuss
Caption: a little bit of Behavioral Science but
Caption: not too much because it's complicated
Caption: and it's kind of a vortex in itself
Caption: and then we're going to look at the
Caption: Practical steps that I took in order to
Caption: overcome distraction these steps are
Caption: aimed at both the external and the
Caption: internal triggers of distraction
Caption: and those triggers are things that
Caption: prompt us towards being distracted
Caption: to wind up I'm going to show you some
Caption: stats that show how I improved my
Caption: performance at work if you're wondering
Caption: where this mostly comes into it it's
Caption: because I'm still finding it pretty
Caption: challenging to overcome distraction and
Caption: procrastination in my personal life
Caption: I'm managing it a bit it's a bit better
Caption: than it was it's a work in progress
Caption: so to get started let's look at
Caption: procrastination
Caption: I think most people are pretty familiar
Caption: with procrastination there's something
Caption: you're supposed to be doing often
Caption: something pretty important
Caption: but for some reason you just can't seem
Caption: to get started on doing it
Caption: instead you're doing something that you
Caption: know for a fact isn't helpful like
Caption: watching TV or scrolling on social media
Caption: or you're doing something that your
Caption: procrastination is sneakily trying to
Caption: pretend is helpful like just clearing my
Caption: desk so I can focus better
Caption: so I think when we think about
Caption: procrastination the instinct is to kind
Caption: of write it off as laziness or lack of
Caption: motivation
Caption: hmm
Caption: sorry excuse me
Caption: um so the fix is easy if you're a better
Caption: person with better self-control you
Caption: wouldn't procrastinate so much
Caption: right now this is obviously ridiculous
Caption: and yet it is the most common way that
Caption: people try and overcome procrastination
Caption: you do so you procrastinate you feel
Caption: guilty about it you beat yourself up
Caption: about it and then you promise yourself
Caption: you're going to do better maybe you even
Caption: do manage to do better for a while
Caption: but eventually you're going to end up
Caption: back a procrastination again
Caption: so why is this I think it's because
Caption: better self-control doesn't address the
Caption: underlying reasons behind
Caption: procrastination
Caption: so
Caption: it doesn't get to the root causes now
Caption: I'm going to show here a list of reasons
Caption: for procrastination and it's pretty
Caption: comprehensive although I think you can
Caption: probably think of some others
Caption: but
Caption: sorry I'm a little bit overwhelmed
Caption: feeling over
Caption: um
Caption: I think
Caption: if we look at this it seems a little bit
Caption: overwhelming in and of itself right this
Caption: is a very small font to be working with
Caption: but I think if we look into it a little
Caption: more closely we can see that these root
Caption: causes or these reasons can be broken
Caption: down into just five root causes or maybe
Caption: it can maybe it can't yes it can
Caption: okay now I'm going to leave out the
Caption: physical and or mental factors
Caption: they're obviously a massive problem for
Caption: a lot of people but it's really above my
Caption: pay grade to be discussing them the only
Caption: thing I can say is that if these things
Caption: are a big issue for you
Caption: then you should address them first
Caption: because otherwise any of the work you
Caption: try and do in any of these other areas
Caption: is going to be undermined
Caption: okay so damn it I keep pressing the
Caption: wrong button right so if we look at
Caption: what's left I think we can see that this
Caption: can be boiled down into just one thing
Caption: avoiding pain
Caption: it might be minor pain like my tax is
Caption: really boring or more significant pain
Caption: like
Caption: I'm really stressed I'm going to do a
Caption: bad job with my DDD talk and end up
Caption: looking like an idiot in front of a
Caption: bunch of people news flash it's kind of
Caption: happening guys so woo
Caption: um
Caption: look wherever it is whatever the reasons
Caption: where it leaves us is avoiding the pain
Caption: in the short term
Caption: but then that often leaves us with
Caption: greater pain in the longer term and
Caption: actually there's a lot of people who
Caption: work in this space that include that in
Caption: their definition of procrastination it's
Caption: not just that we're putting off an
Caption: important task is also the knowledge
Caption: that we're going to be worse off for
Caption: having deleted we know this is what's
Caption: going to happen
Caption: and yet I do it all the time and that
Caption: brings us back to
Caption: you why are you like this why am I like
Caption: this
Caption: okay well I think if we look at a couple
Caption: of examples
Caption: let's start with tax like I was talking
Caption: about before it's really boring right so
Caption: the first reason is Task aversion it's
Caption: boring and it sucks and because I don't
Caption: want to do this boring task that sucks
Caption: throughout the year I Leave It All To
Caption: the End
Caption: where it takes longer and is therefore
Caption: more boring
Caption: and because it takes longer I need
Caption: elevated levels of perseverance but I
Caption: don't have that because the task is
Caption: boring and it sucks
Caption: now that could explain everything right
Caption: it's boring it sucks no wonder I want to
Caption: procrastinate but actually if we dig a
Caption: little further into it there are a
Caption: couple of things around the future that
Caption: come into play
Caption: so
Caption: it doesn't take me long to do my tax
Caption: right it's maybe like an hour and a half
Caption: and the government is just going to give
Caption: me money they're just going to give it
Caption: to me
Caption: why wouldn't I just do it
Caption: well
Caption: the thing is by the time I accountant
Caption: files and the government processes it's
Caption: kind of a little bit far in the future
Caption: so there's a delayed outcome it's not
Caption: like there's a guy standing next to me
Caption: with a lot of cash going if you do this
Caption: for an hour you can have this
Caption: and it's not even that far in the future
Caption: but the reason it becomes important is
Caption: because there's a disconnect with My
Caption: Future Self
Caption: I'm like
Caption: I'm doing all this work so her in three
Caption: weeks time gets a cash present what am I
Caption: getting out of this now what I'm getting
Caption: out of it is obviously the cash present
Caption: because I'm the same person but in the
Caption: moment it doesn't feel like that
Caption: the last thing is that this is a bit of
Caption: an abstract goal I don't have anything
Caption: specifically that I'm saving for there's
Caption: nothing I've really earmarked this money
Caption: for
Caption: so
Caption: there's not really anything specific
Caption: that would make me
Caption: motivated to strive to do this
Caption: now if we look at another task oh sorry
Caption: gone a little bit far if we're going to
Caption: look at another task which is a
Caption: development task that I had to do at
Caption: work
Caption: so we had a bit of a collaborative
Caption: strategy meeting about what I would be
Caption: doing but it wasn't something I'd done
Caption: before so I didn't really know what I
Caption: was doing so the first one as you got a
Caption: preview of is indecisiveness there were
Caption: a couple of different paths I could take
Caption: because I hadn't done it before I didn't
Caption: know which one would be the best one
Caption: I was also feeling a little bit
Caption: overwhelmed because I hadn't done it
Caption: before
Caption: I was a little bit out of my depth
Caption: then I had general anxiety specifically
Caption: around the deadline because it was a
Caption: hard deadline and I knew that I had to
Caption: meet it it was a hard deadline that was
Caption: a little bit tight actually so the
Caption: pressure was on
Caption: then there's fear of evaluation and this
Caption: one is because my leader is this like
Caption: insane code Whisperer genius person and
Caption: that's usually a really good thing but
Caption: it always adds an extra level of fear
Caption: about how good my code is
Caption: then there's a bit of task aversion in
Caption: this one as well
Caption: and that's mainly because I could help
Caption: this by doing a little bit of research
Caption: but I really find going on to like stack
Caption: Overflow or
Caption: browsing through random repos usually a
Caption: bit tedious
Caption: so if we put all that together it's not
Caption: hard to see where I want to put this off
Caption: right if I don't even think about this
Caption: task I'm going to be saving myself a lot
Caption: of discomfort
Caption: but that's only in the short term in the
Caption: long term
Caption: I'm going to be adding fear of failure
Caption: to my list because if I waste time
Caption: there's a real possibility that I'm
Caption: going to miss the deadline
Caption: all right sorry
Caption: um so you can see my reasons for
Caption: procrastination with both of these
Caption: things were very different
Caption: okay
Caption: now we've discovered what my reasons for
Caption: doing this were let's see what we can do
Caption: to help me from stop to stop me from
Caption: procrastinating
Caption: this is again a comprehensive list with
Caption: quite small font of some of the common
Caption: things that people suggest that you
Caption: might use to overcome procrastination
Caption: how
Caption: um
Caption: I think this is probably a lot to take
Caption: in but the one I would suggest paying
Caption: attention to the most is this figuring
Caption: out the exact nature of your
Caption: procrastination problem which is what we
Caption: just went through there
Caption: I think this should always be the first
Caption: step
Caption: because the reasons that we process
Caption: procrastinate as we just saw are always
Caption: very different and that means that you
Caption: need different tools to overcome it you
Caption: can't apply the same stuff in every
Caption: situation
Caption: okay
Caption: so
Caption: if we return to my tax problem these are
Caption: all the reasons that I was
Caption: procrastinating
Caption: and we'll look at how I'm going to
Caption: overcome this one so task aversion I'm
Caption: going to address by making a low bar
Caption: commitment
Caption: what I'm going to do in this case is to
Caption: say
Caption: work on this for five minutes and then
Caption: you can do 10 minutes of whatever you
Caption: want I'm going to work on it for five
Caption: minutes again then I can do 10 minutes
Caption: of whatever I want now this is going to
Caption: work for me for a couple of reasons
Caption: because it's extremely short term I'm
Caption: going to get a reward almost straight
Caption: away
Caption: it's going to stop me from feeling
Caption: guilty about prioritizing my short-term
Caption: mood because actually now that I've said
Caption: I can have those 10 minutes of reward
Caption: those 10 minutes are no longer
Caption: procrastination they're actually what I
Caption: said I was going to do in my plan
Caption: it's also going to get me started on the
Caption: task so I can stop feeling guilty that
Caption: I'm putting it off
Caption: I don't have to have that dread hanging
Caption: over me that oh God I really should do
Caption: it
Caption: this is also going to address my lack of
Caption: perseverance
Caption: because I only have to do it for five
Caption: minutes
Caption: it's not really needing that much
Caption: self-control to keep going with it
Caption: the key thing with this is obviously
Caption: once you get started on a task
Caption: five minutes can slip away really
Caption: quickly and actually find out it's not
Caption: as bad as you thought it was so now that
Caption: I've got myself started I'm probably
Caption: going to be engrossed and when the five
Caption: minutes are up
Caption: I'm maybe not going to want to actually
Caption: stop I'm probably halfway through
Caption: something that I don't want to leave
Caption: unfinished
Caption: so I've got myself moving
Caption: so my abstract goal I'm going to address
Caption: by attaching meaning to the task now
Caption: there's a couple of things that I can
Caption: attach meaning to here firstly there's
Caption: the reward which is getting my return
Caption: secondly there's the negative outcome of
Caption: getting a fine from the ATO which has
Caption: happened to me before
Caption: okay and I actually get fairly
Caption: frustrated with myself when I end up
Caption: with a stupid fine over nothing that was
Caption: completely avoidable so what I'm gonna
Caption: do
Caption: is visualize the outcomes of me doing
Caption: this work or in that case not doing the
Caption: work I can remind myself that I'm going
Caption: to be really frustrated if I get a fine
Caption: and then I can also visualize that I'm
Caption: going to get this little return it's
Caption: going to be in my bank balance it's
Caption: going to be a great time
Caption: okay I'm also going to reward myself and
Caption: that's going to
Caption: help me with the delayed outcomes
Caption: problem it's not an immediate reward
Caption: like my 10 minutes what it's going to be
Caption: is something tangible
Caption: so I'm going to get my return from the
Caption: government
Caption: and then what I'm going to do with that
Caption: is actually say I'm going to buy x with
Caption: it specifically something that I want
Caption: right
Caption: and then I'm going to say to myself
Caption: you're not allowed to buy eggs
Caption: unless you do your tax return
Caption: so now this is my task at work that I
Caption: was procrastinating on
Caption: there's my little things including the
Caption: fear of failure that came in at the end
Caption: and I'm gonna address my indecisiveness
Caption: by sitting down with someone for five
Caption: minutes and having them act as my rubber
Caption: ducky I'm gonna have a little
Caption: conversation I'm going to be able to
Caption: outline my thoughts more clearly and I'm
Caption: going to clarify how I'm going to work
Caption: to towards a solution
Caption: now their input is also going to give me
Caption: other ideas or other avenues that I
Caption: might want to explore
Caption: that's also going to help me with my
Caption: feeling overwhelm my feeling of being
Caption: overwhelmed
Caption: because now I've got a plan in place
Caption: I'm further going to help my
Caption: indecisiveness and my feeling of being
Caption: overwhelmed by creating and implementing
Caption: a plan
Caption: what I'm going to do is break this large
Caption: task down into small and manageable
Caption: tasks
Caption: and then
Caption: I'm going to set an intermediate
Caption: deadline for each of those tasks that's
Caption: going to help me with my deadline
Caption: anxiety
Caption: because now I'm going to be able to see
Caption: if I'm getting off track
Caption: and I'm going to be able to manage my
Caption: time more effectively
Caption: this is also going to help me with my
Caption: fear of failure because if I know that
Caption: I'm on track all the time or if I know
Caption: I'm getting off track I can ask for
Caption: other tasks to be reassigned I can ask
Caption: for another developer to come in and
Caption: give me support any of that kind of
Caption: stuff so I'm no longer worried that I'm
Caption: going to miss the deadline it's just not
Caption: going to happen anymore
Caption: my fear of evaluation oh sorry
Caption: I'm now in a good place to make a low
Caption: bar commitment even though this task is
Caption: much bigger than the the tax task I can
Caption: still get myself going by saying I'll
Caption: just do five minutes because I've got
Caption: all these interim tasks that are much
Caption: smaller
Caption: they're not as overwhelming to think
Caption: about as the full thing I don't have to
Caption: keep putting it off because I know that
Caption: there are smaller tasks that I can do
Caption: the other thing my tasks are going to do
Caption: is allow me to choose the order I do
Caption: them carefully so for some people this
Caption: looks like getting the least attractive
Caption: thing out the way right Someone I used
Caption: to work with used to say if you have to
Caption: eat a frog eat it first thing
Caption: there's another group of people who like
Caption: to get themselves motivated
Caption: feeling good about themselves and psych
Caption: themselves up by Crossing off a few
Caption: little tasks you've got a couple of wins
Caption: in the bag you've had a couple little
Caption: things that you've ticked off and so
Caption: you're feeling good and ready to go on
Caption: to the other stuff it doesn't really
Caption: matter which type of person you are
Caption: but if you understand which type then
Caption: you can choose your task order carefully
Caption: and that can also help you avoid
Caption: procrastination
Caption: now
Caption: I'm going to talk about prioritizing
Caption: your tasks by importance which sounds
Caption: like a kind of counterman's the one
Caption: we've just said but they work together
Caption: because one of the caveats of choosing
Caption: your task order is that you can actually
Caption: use the subtasks to procrastinate on the
Caption: main task because procrastination is
Caption: very sneaky
Caption: of had a file open it's the file I'm
Caption: supposed to be working on I'm literally
Caption: working on it I'm like writing code and
Caption: it's still procrastination because it
Caption: isn't the task that I opened the file to
Caption: do
Caption: the reason I'm choosing to do this
Caption: little easy task fixing up the way the
Caption: header displays is because I'm
Caption: procrastinating on the more daunting
Caption: part of the task
Caption: so I'm gonna avoid that by also
Caption: prioritizing if I'm the sort of person
Caption: that needs to psych myself up I'm going
Caption: to give myself permission to do one or
Caption: two little things and then straight into
Caption: the next one
Caption: so my fear of evaluation I'm going to
Caption: sort out by acknowledging that my work
Caption: is going to have some flaws
Caption: and the thing about my flaws is
Caption: they're not a reflection on my worth as
Caption: a person which is how it can feel
Caption: sometimes right
Caption: actually they're a learning opportunity
Caption: it's something that I'm going to know
Caption: better for next time
Caption: now everything I've done so far actually
Caption: helps me with my task aversion because
Caption: I'm a lot clearer on what it is that I'm
Caption: doing
Caption: I don't have to well probably won't have
Caption: to go and consult the internet right I
Caption: don't have to consult it straight away I
Caption: might not have to at all
Caption: if I do I'm going to be able to be more
Caption: focused in what I'm searching for I'm
Caption: not doing generalized research I'm going
Caption: to be looking for specific problem
Caption: solving
Caption: so that is also going to be addressed
Caption: all right so you can see that on the
Caption: surface these things look similar right
Caption: it was two tasks I was putting them off
Caption: I knew it was a bad idea
Caption: probably I'm just a bad person right
Caption: actually
Caption: if we look at it closely what we can see
Caption: is not only is this not a moral failing
Caption: on my part but the reasons are so
Caption: different that my strategies need to be
Caption: different to deal with them as well and
Caption: that's what I want you to remember about
Caption: procrastination
Caption: now I'm going to move on to the second
Caption: part of the presentation and talk about
Caption: distraction
Caption: now
Caption: I'm not going to be all down on
Caption: technology
Caption: I love technology
Caption: but
Caption: I think it's important for us to admit
Caption: out loud that in this wonderful world
Caption: we've built of instantaneous connection
Caption: and instantaneous content there are more
Caption: things competing for our attention than
Caption: ever before
Caption: and a lot of those things were designed
Caption: to specifically hook us in they're
Caption: leveraging that brain pattern to keep us
Caption: coming back again and again
Caption: right it's not really surprising under
Caption: these circumstances that we find
Caption: ourselves getting sucked into the Vortex
Caption: maybe we're scrolling endlessly on
Caption: social media
Caption: maybe we're binging a whole TV series
Caption: maybe we're hooked on a notification
Caption: badge or we find ourselves unable to let
Caption: an email go unanswered even though we're
Caption: in the middle of a task
Caption: now this might seem innocuous
Caption: like does it really matter if you take
Caption: 30 seconds out of your day to answer an
Caption: email and actually it kind of does and
Caption: we're going to come back to that
Caption: you might also think
Caption: if I'm just sitting at home on the couch
Caption: after work shouldn't I be able to scroll
Caption: as much as I want
Caption: and yeah maybe you should
Caption: but where it becomes a problem is where
Caption: distraction stops us from doing the
Caption: things that are really important to us
Caption: so in your personal life that might look
Caption: like you not being as present for your
Caption: kids as you'd like it might look like
Caption: you're not fully pulling the weight in
Caption: your relationship
Caption: it might look like your house being in
Caption: an advanced state of chaos all the time
Caption: whatever it is it's likely to be
Caption: something that you're aware of and it's
Caption: likely to be something that causes you
Caption: pain and you know how we like to deal
Caption: with pain
Caption: procrastination and that's how you end
Caption: up in that Loop where at the end of the
Caption: weekend you've only got a tenth of your
Caption: tasks done and you know full well it's
Caption: your own fault because you spent most of
Caption: the time binging Netflix
Caption: um
Caption: so
Caption: when this happens we're most likely
Caption: going to end up back at
Caption: why are you like this I do it a lot
Caption: okay
Caption: like procrastination the most easy
Caption: solution easy solution to distraction
Caption: is better self-control again if you're a
Caption: better person you wouldn't spend as much
Caption: time mindlessly scrolling
Caption: now I'm going to go into a little bit of
Caption: this complicated Behavioral Science we
Caption: spoke about before
Caption: because I want to explain to you
Caption: something that's called ironic process
Caption: Theory because this shows why better
Caption: self-control
Caption: mental abstinence
Caption: which is
Caption: using your self-control to stop yourself
Caption: from doing something that you actually
Caption: really want to do isn't the answer to
Caption: distraction
Caption: so it starts with this quote which is
Caption: from Dostoyevsky
Caption: try to pose for yourself this task not
Caption: to think of a white bear and you will
Caption: see that the curse thing will come to
Caption: mind every minute
Caption: he's an outlaw guys
Caption: so fast forwarding 120 odd years a
Caption: social psychologist called Daniel Wagner
Caption: decided to put this to the task he
Caption: really liked this quote so he was like
Caption: let's do an experiment
Caption: so he had two groups one group was told
Caption: specifically to think of a white bear
Caption: for five minutes one group was told
Caption: specifically to not think of a white
Caption: bear now the group that was told not to
Caption: failed miserably they did it on average
Caption: once a minute and that's kind of what
Caption: we're expecting because this quote Rings
Caption: true for most people right
Caption: the interesting part is the second half
Caption: of the experiment was to tell both
Caption: groups to think of the white bear
Caption: and when they did that the group that
Caption: had initially suppressed the thoughts of
Caption: the white bear actually brought the
Caption: white bed to mind more readily than the
Caption: group who had been told to think of it
Caption: all along
Caption: what Wagner found is that if you try and
Caption: suppress thoughts of something it
Caption: actually makes you more susceptible to
Caption: that thing this is called behavioral
Caption: rebound and it works in everything from
Caption: like
Caption: trying to control addiction to trying to
Caption: suppress your laughter
Caption: all right
Caption: so
Caption: there are a couple of techniques that
Caption: you can find for trying to deal with
Caption: intrusive thoughts that are brought to
Caption: mind that cause behavioral rebound but
Caption: they're mostly for things like if you're
Caption: quitting smoking
Caption: for distraction I've found the easiest
Caption: way to deal with it is just to remove
Caption: the stimulus
Caption: right
Caption: I know that I'm susceptible to alerts
Caption: and notifications so what I'm going to
Caption: do is simply stop that from being able
Caption: to happen
Caption: so I started with the biggest culprit
Caption: which was my phone
Caption: I just reconfigured it so I uninstalled
Caption: some apps goodbye Reddit goodbye
Caption: wordscapes
Caption: and it didn't take long for me to be
Caption: broken from the habit of those two
Caption: things right
Caption: and actually an interesting thing
Caption: happened which is that my nieces asked
Caption: me if they could reinstall wordscapes
Caption: and I let them
Caption: because they like to play it it's like
Caption: all right it's a problem for me but okay
Caption: and actually as it turns out it wasn't a
Caption: problem for me
Caption: I know it's there it's still there it's
Caption: still installed I never open it they use
Caption: it and they're the only ones who do
Caption: and that's because I broke the habit
Caption: the second thing that I did with my
Caption: phone was to configure the notifications
Caption: so I've always had lock screen
Caption: notification disabled that's just how I
Caption: roll but I did always have like an audio
Caption: alert that comes up you get a little
Caption: ping you're like oh what's this and you
Caption: go and look at it right
Caption: so what I did with that was I actually
Caption: configured my do not disturb so that I
Caption: can have it switched on permanently
Caption: so what I let come through is nothing
Caption: but phone calls I decided I want pretty
Caption: much anyone to always be able to get me
Caption: on the phone
Caption: maybe not your telemarketers but if
Caption: something important or crucial is going
Caption: to happen to my friends to my family
Caption: they're gonna pick up the phone and call
Caption: me so anyone can always call me but
Caption: apart from that everything else is
Caption: completely silent so now the only way
Caption: that I know if I've got a text message
Caption: an email from a non-work account
Caption: a notification from one of the like four
Caption: different instant messaging platforms I
Caption: have
Caption: is if I pick up my phone and unlock it
Caption: and explicitly look for it
Caption: this is a great time saver for me
Caption: because I'm just not picking up my phone
Caption: as much
Caption: all right
Caption: excuse me
Caption: now
Caption: the next thing I'm going to talk about
Caption: was
Caption: sorry the next thing I'm going to talk
Caption: about is actually dealing with the
Caption: internal triggers of distraction so you
Caption: can see the stuff that I've talked about
Caption: already is external triggers there's a
Caption: little noise I'm prompting to pick up my
Caption: phone but there are also internal
Caption: triggers and for me they come up
Caption: in my moments of peak distractibility
Caption: and they're all internal so it's like
Caption: I've finished one task and I'm going to
Caption: start another
Caption: and I'm just going to pick up my phone
Caption: and you know send a text
Caption: I've
Caption: um
Caption: finished a job that I was going to do
Caption: and I feel like I need to reward myself
Caption: in those moments I'm most susceptible to
Caption: distractibility because I'm not just
Caption: going to pick up this thing and look at
Caption: it for a few seconds I'm going to keep
Caption: doing it one of the ones I do a lot of
Caption: the time is like when something is
Caption: loading or I'm waiting for a two-factor
Caption: authentication something like that this
Caption: is literally like a 10 second period but
Caption: I can't go for those 10 seconds without
Caption: being entertained I just can't
Caption: so all these triggers I need a different
Caption: approach to be able to
Caption: deal with now the first thing I did was
Caption: still configuring my tech
Caption: and that was to disable Google discover
Caption: do you all know what Google discover is
Caption: are you familiar with this it's it's
Caption: this thing
Caption: this is a little screenshot of mine
Caption: I haven't looked at the begonia yet I am
Caption: still interested
Caption: so this was a massive Vortex for me
Caption: because actually Google is really good
Caption: at knowing what I'm into begonias
Caption: cat memes it's all good
Caption: and the problem was that once I had
Caption: disabled Reddit it was also popping up
Caption: like a lot of well obviously cat memes
Caption: but also a lot of like Agony art content
Caption: that I had previously been seeing on
Caption: Reddit and I ended up in a little bit of
Caption: a spiral where I was actually reading
Caption: like Reddit aita posts but just
Caption: screenshotted on a Content aggregator
Caption: website
Caption: which is just so I was like all right
Caption: Google discover you've got to go
Caption: okay so I think I think at one point I
Caption: had looked at an article that one of my
Caption: friends had posted and accidentally gave
Caption: it the impression that I care about
Caption: infant Health Care in any way which I
Caption: don't
Caption: but apart from that it was nailing it
Caption: with the cat memes the agony art stuff
Caption: right so
Caption: what I did was to just disable it and it
Caption: was a bit of a problem actually to try
Caption: and do that because how it worked for me
Caption: was just a single swipe from my home
Caption: screen I had to Google quite deeply to
Caption: work out how to turn that functionality
Caption: off but I managed it and once I'd done
Caption: it it was really noticeable just how
Caption: many times a day I reached for it
Caption: because I would swipe and I'd do it a
Caption: couple of times because it hadn't worked
Caption: and then I'd be like Oh I'm doing that
Caption: thing again
Caption: and the interesting thing about this is
Caption: like before this content is actually
Caption: available to me at any time if I open a
Caption: new blank tab in Chrome it's just there
Caption: that's the default Behavior but because
Caption: I broke the little reflex of swiping it
Caption: also
Caption: delivered a pretty big hit to the mental
Caption: part of it as well
Caption: now unfortunately
Caption: just disabling this one app is not
Caption: enough to deal completely with my
Caption: internal triggers of distraction I also
Caption: needed a strategy to be able to do that
Caption: so the first thing is I'm going to have
Caption: to notice the trigger and ideally has to
Caption: be in the moment you can kind of do it
Caption: as a retrospective like all right I just
Caption: put my phone down after looking at it
Caption: for 10 minutes when I was just
Caption: waiting for two-factor authentication
Caption: whoops
Caption: but it's better if you notice it at the
Caption: time you're doing it and for me
Caption: disabling Google discover was a really
Caption: good thing for this because like I said
Caption: super noticeable when I tried to do it
Caption: and it didn't work
Caption: now the second step
Caption: is that I'm going to explore the
Caption: feelings I'm not going to judge myself
Caption: and be like oh you're a bad person what
Caption: I'm going to do is just think about it
Caption: for a while
Caption: get curious wonder why I'm wanting to be
Caption: distracted and as before with my
Caption: procrastination when I'm thinking about
Caption: why I want to procrastinate
Caption: it is
Caption: easier for me to understand and sit in
Caption: the moment if I've interrogated a little
Caption: bit it's kind of like Wagner's second
Caption: group of people maybe first group of
Caption: people the people who are allowed to
Caption: think about the bear the whole time I'm
Caption: not going to be rebounding
Caption: because I'm allowing myself to think
Caption: about it I'm not trying to suppress that
Caption: thought
Caption: the third thing
Caption: is that I'm just going to wait for 10
Caption: minutes so this is like making a low bar
Caption: commitment to yourself with
Caption: procrastination you just say I'm gonna
Caption: wait for 10 minutes it's super easy to
Caption: do
Caption: but actually
Caption: once you've noticed a trigger and you've
Caption: explored the feelings then the waiting
Caption: is usually enough of a period to help
Caption: you cool off
Caption: right and you kind of know that you're
Caption: not supposed to be getting distracted so
Caption: it allows you to
Caption: sit with those feelings but not have to
Caption: feel guilty about them because you've
Caption: already made this bargain with yourself
Caption: if I wait for 10 minutes I still want to
Caption: do the thing after I'm allowed to do the
Caption: thing I don't have to feel guilty when I
Caption: do the thing because I already gave
Caption: myself permission I've already worked
Caption: through that
Caption: excuse me
Caption: all right now I just want to talk
Caption: specifically about distractions at work
Caption: because I think they look a little bit
Caption: different to how distractions in your
Caption: personal life work
Caption: at work a lot of my distractions kind of
Caption: look a lot like plain old work because
Caption: that's mostly what they are they're
Caption: often a small task that's come in
Caption: it's often pretty urgent it's often
Caption: something that is low impact or low
Caption: importance it's not usually the big
Caption: strategic stuff that I'm really trying
Caption: to work towards
Caption: and because distraction is just as
Caption: sneaky as procrastination
Caption: we think to ourselves oh yeah that is
Caption: important I will just do that thing
Caption: and where you end up is in this cycle of
Caption: churning stuff through
Caption: and switching tasks frequently
Caption: now
Caption: the reason this is a problem for me is
Caption: because I am easily distracted so if
Caption: someone sends me an email my instinct is
Caption: to jump on what they do what they sent
Caption: to me and do it straight away okay
Caption: so my problem at work was pretty much
Caption: similar to in my personal life it was
Caption: notifications notifications and
Caption: notifications
Caption: because at work we have email obviously
Caption: we have slack within our web team
Caption: we have Asana for our broader
Caption: Communications team so get task
Caption: notifications and then we use teams for
Caption: the whole organization and anyone can
Caption: talk to me through that it's a lot of
Caption: noise every day
Caption: so as with my phone
Caption: I changed this up by just turning all
Caption: these off so I now check it probably
Caption: like three to five times a day check all
Caption: of those channels and apart from that I
Caption: have Outlook closed because if you just
Caption: turn off the notifications you can still
Caption: see there's a new email
Caption: I explicitly have to quit teams in the
Caption: system tray because if you just close it
Caption: it looks like it's closed but if you get
Caption: a notification it pops up
Caption: and then I have slack muted and then
Caption: closed because if you just close it you
Caption: can still see a little notification
Caption: badge and you can see what I was talking
Caption: about before with this
Caption: um apps trying to hook us in right
Caption: I had to be quite ingenious with all
Caption: these things to try and stop them from
Caption: being able to reach me and distract me
Caption: um
Caption: sorry
Caption: as for Asana what I did with that was I
Caption: turned off the notifications in slack so
Caption: we had an integration it would send you
Caption: a message every time that happened
Caption: and then I set up a rule in my email to
Caption: send all of the notifications to a
Caption: folder that I never look at so there's
Caption: now
Caption: 1166 unread emails in that folder I'm
Caption: pretty proud of that thank you
Caption: and the reason I didn't just disable
Caption: them entirely is because asana's kind of
Caption: hard to use sometimes and sometimes that
Caption: is the best way of finding something
Caption: specific that I'm looking for so I
Caption: didn't want to get rid of the emails
Caption: altogether but I don't want them
Caption: cluttering up my inbox
Caption: so does this seem pretty extreme
Caption: it kind of seemed extreme to me when I
Caption: was first doing it so one of the key
Caption: things was to manage other people's
Caption: expectations so this is my leader our
Caption: unit manager everyone else in the web
Caption: team and then a couple of other people
Caption: that I support frequently I told them
Caption: that if they needed to get me urgently
Caption: then they should pick up the phone and
Caption: call me and otherwise you can try your
Caption: luck at any time but I might not respond
Caption: straight away
Caption: and actually it did raise a few eyebrows
Caption: people were a bit like
Caption: so you're just not gonna let people talk
Caption: to you about work
Caption: but actually as it turns out people
Caption: rarely ever notice that I'm offline for
Caption: most of the day and nobody has ever
Caption: picked up the phone to call me
Caption: it seemed pretty daunting to me when I
Caption: was first doing it and I think that was
Caption: because I was in this always on always
Caption: available mindset
Caption: which I think a lot of us are right
Caption: but it causes no inconvenience to anyone
Caption: else and it does make me a lot more
Caption: effective at work
Caption: because like I said
Caption: I'm pretty easily distracted I will jump
Caption: on the nearest thing that came in
Caption: and then also because it stops me from
Caption: task switching so frequently
Caption: and now this is where we're going to
Caption: come back to why does it matter if I
Caption: take 30 seconds out of my day to reply
Caption: to that email
Caption: the reason it matters is because with
Caption: frequent task switching you're actually
Caption: raising your cognitive load okay so
Caption: cognitive load means it's going to be
Caption: harder for you to focus back on your
Caption: first task your brain is going to be
Caption: more tired and you're also going to be
Caption: much more likely to make a mistake
Caption: and that's a problem because I was doing
Caption: a lot of task switching
Caption: I think being at work can feel like
Caption: sharing out a single bucket of water
Caption: amongst all the fires
Caption: that are surrounding you
Caption: and you give them all just enough to
Caption: kind of keep them under control but it's
Caption: not enough to douse them usually
Caption: and you end up task switching a lot
Caption: because you need to put out your fires
Caption: now
Caption: to address this problem which I was
Caption: having a lot
Caption: I further switched up my day I'm going
Caption: to show you now my task tracking
Caption: software
Caption: and this is what it looked like before
Caption: I started doing all this stuff so you
Caption: can see here
Caption: I'm doing I mean Tuesday was pretty good
Caption: actually
Caption: yay Tuesday but like Wednesday was a
Caption: complete mess and these are all the
Caption: tasks I'm doing I'm doing like 11
Caption: minutes 25 minutes 26 minutes 17 minutes
Caption: 22 minutes is because I'm still
Caption: available to anyone and everyone at this
Caption: time so I'm getting emails in and
Caption: replying to them I'm getting teams
Caption: things I'm also in the mindset of I'll
Caption: just get that out the way
Caption: right because I've got a load of like
Caption: very small tasks they're very minor I
Caption: can get those done really quickly and
Caption: then I'll get on with the rest of my day
Caption: and actually what you can see here is
Caption: that I'm mostly not getting on with the
Caption: rest of my day
Caption: I'm ending up
Caption: not being able to focus really even that
Caption: well in the afternoon either I'm doing I
Caption: mean especially Wednesday
Caption: what a problem but then all the rest of
Caption: them I'm still you know kind of managing
Caption: maybe an hour-ish a little bit more than
Caption: an hour and you can see where I'm most
Caption: effective is after 4pm on Friday and
Caption: that's because nobody could talk to me
Caption: and
Caption: I'm working well and truly past six
Caption: because I have a lot of stuff that I
Caption: didn't get to do this week because I was
Caption: doing all this other little crappy stuff
Caption: okay
Caption: so here's what it looked like after I
Caption: started implementing this so you can see
Caption: I've still got mostly quite a smallish
Caption: task up front
Caption: and that's me doing my emails checking
Caption: teams checking slack replying to
Caption: anything that needs a bit of back and
Caption: forth and then I'm also going into Asana
Caption: and planning my day and then I'm jumping
Caption: straight into the meaty stuff
Caption: I'm focusing for much longer periods of
Caption: time and then when I come back after
Caption: lunch you can see on some of the days
Caption: like Monday I'm still doing the little
Caption: tasks
Caption: but on other days I'm doing a lot more
Caption: focus in the afternoon as well so it's
Caption: like I'm still surrounded by fires but
Caption: actually now I'm just letting them burn
Caption: and it turns out
Caption: I didn't need to give them as much
Caption: attention as I was they actually coped
Caption: just as well being left alone for a
Caption: while
Caption: the last thing I'm going to finish with
Caption: is a little bit of my Asana so this is
Caption: the six months before this is how many
Caption: tasks I did for context a task for us is
Caption: anything from like 15 minutes to four
Caption: weeks so it varies quite a lot
Caption: I'd say probably 60 of the tasks are
Caption: probably one to six hours right
Caption: so in the six months before I've done
Caption: 187 tasks this is about one and a
Caption: quarter tasks per day which is I don't
Caption: know seems kind of okay I'm not sure
Caption: this is the six months after so it's
Caption: gone up like a little bit but actually
Caption: this encompasses the period that I was
Caption: on leave for over Christmas so actually
Caption: now my daily rate is now 1.93 which is a
Caption: lot better than 1.25 go at me but I was
Caption: still kind of refining my process at the
Caption: time
Caption: so in the four months since then
Caption: I've now done 246 so I've done more
Caption: tasks in four months than I did in six
Caption: months and I'm now up to 2.93 tasks per
Caption: day
Caption: which is more than double what it was
Caption: before
Caption: I'm pretty impressed by it I hadn't
Caption: actually I think
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: I hadn't actually looked at stats before
Caption: doing this talk I was just kind of going
Caption: with like the vibe feels more productive
Caption: I think I'm getting more done turns out
Caption: I was getting more done go me
Caption: so I'm just going to finish up by
Caption: telling you what I think the key
Caption: takeaways are so
Caption: I think understanding the reasons we
Caption: procrastinate and looking into it helps
Caption: us to choose the best technique to
Caption: overcome procrastination
Caption: distraction
Caption: can stop us from doing the things that
Caption: are really important to us whether it's
Caption: deploying a new feature or letting the
Caption: people we care about know that we're
Caption: fully present when we're with them
Caption: we can deal with a lot of the external
Caption: triggers of distraction by just
Caption: configuring our Tech we can deal with
Caption: the internal triggers not by suppressing
Caption: our thoughts which can lead to rebound
Caption: but by being Mindful and sitting in our
Caption: feelings in the moment
Caption: and you might get a bit of pushback if
Caption: you try and configure this stuff at work
Caption: but ultimately the results you're going
Caption: to get are going to be pretty good
Caption: and that's all thank you for coming
Caption: [Applause]